plaignants tout le monde s'est choisi
aujourd'hui on se trouve sur the
midnight game un jeu d'horreur et je
sais pas pourquoi mais à chaque fois que
j'ai la voix enrouée ou cassé j'ai envie
qu'on joue un jeu d'horreur c'est
complètement débile instruction le
matériel rue qui inclut une bougie votre
porte d'entrée principale en bois très
bien comme ça je dis bienvenue à tous
les cambrioleurs de la planète
ensuite il faut un peu de mon sens est
un bout de papier et des allumettes
basse est parti à la recherche de tous
ces objets bas mon sens il faut se
trouve et et d'un couteau pour couper un
bras
c'est une sorte de ps4 ou alors un mix
surtout la ps4 et xbox ont annoncé lés
manette de ps3 je comprends plus rien je
vais retrouver tous ces objets en
commençant par annoncer ses dehors très
bien finalement ils peuvent carrément
rentrée par là les cambrioleurs d'accord
il ya des allumettes là mon gars on va
se mettre bien debout sur la table juste
pour les ramasser il faut une bougie ou
des cracotte ça replace bien une bougie
dekra cote n'est pas l'heure de manger
des céréales
y aurait-il pas quelques cracotte
maudite [ __ ] a en fait c'est un piège
comme ça comme aulas quand elle
arriverait il marchera sur les cracks
quote ça va craquer on entendra et la
rappellera la police une bougie ben
voilà un couteau donc là on a des
allumettes un couteau basse et pour le
sens le couteau bah voilà ce coupé le
doigt bien comme il faut c'est parfait
c'est mieux qu'un couteau qui avec un
cure-dent rendu moins on le sait et ben
c'est pas mal à tambacounda qui bloque
notre côté ou quoi tout comme valeur est
déjà là c'est vrai qu'il faut à porte
d'entrée j'ai oublié ça car mon bizarre
pour un rituel
il faut ta porte d'entrée voilà bon on
veut pas tarnac et après c'est promis
mais il nous la faut et ton contrat de
travail incite à canon cité voilà en
fait j'ai tout foirer déjà déjà parce
que c'est leur faire le rituel et c'est
trop tard et ensuite parce que là où
j'ai marqué mon nom prénom itou j'ai
écrit une lettre pour ma grand mère déjà
à cette bougie je la veux comment je
fais pour elle et elle est pas allumer
ce que si je colle la mèche longtemps
contre une ampoule ça va l'allumer avec
la chaleur de la lampe à l'homme match
car mon match 6 fallu mettre au hockey
comme angers il faut que je tienne
toutes les lumières harmattan elle est
carrément immense en fait cette maison
c'est quoi ça ok une chambre d'enfant
nickel des doigts et voit ainsi sa
master switch c'est bon faut que je
prenne et que je mette devant la porte
d'entrée
ah non non j'ai fait l'étape 3 à voir la
fin de l'étape de juger moi je me
souviens juste j'avais lui fait écho aux
toqués gtalk et pop up aller au trot ou
au galop monga hop ni call on va être la
lumière on va revenir on va lui mais la
bougie ouais mais si je suis dans le
noir en chine pour revenir on reste mrd
ah oui les la structure principale je
pensais que aussi sur les deux plages
disait ni cas où est le problème et y en
a pas de problème ce passera du tout le
minatd man il ya encore un au peuple à
côté en fait là on fait ce rituel pour
attirer un vilain mecs dans notre maison
qui attendait on va on va re lire les
différentes étapes
étape 3 il faut taper 22 fois sur notre
porte d'entrée hockey et doit être
minuit quand on fait ça ok donc à minuit
il faut que ce soit le 22e coup on se
sur la bougie on l'a rallume et of the
mean that man est là et il nous fait
coucou voire même nous invite au pub
avec un peu de chance vous octobre inter
ou l'extérieur aussi trop de questions
elle et il n'y a pas une pendule et
ouvre toi
mais ouvre toi tu as même les portes
sont possédés ça suffit faut la pousser
de tête à ok retournons à la porte pour
toquer 22 fois à je voulu casser ce vase
mais apparemment il est en mousse c'est
bon ce parti s'est fait faucher sur la
bougie je crois à dos d'autant rallume
la radem non au nom n'a on a échoué
on est encore échoué nous sommes prêts
et cette fois je vous jure quoi pas
perdre à cause des allumettes tu veux
pas c'est lui mais en plus c'est
scandaleux
d'où son nom allumettes allumé hockey
plus de 800 euros dépensés dans des
allumettes
tout ça pour réussir cette difficile
tâche qui influa par les bas à l'eau y
at il quelqu'un j'ai toqué 22 fois via
monsieur midnight manas a buggé ah je
vous tuerai tous même si j'habite dans
un [ __ ] tu as un cas perso non mais
mais j'avais oublié fallait que j'essaye
la bougie en soufflant dessus
ça va être à nous d'entrer en action je
suis prêt à lui mais surtout je pourrais
la rallumer
ok ok c'est bon on a réussi mon gars
alors il est où il est au big date mal
moi je lui serrerai la main quand même
en trois manches s'il vous plaît 1
c'était pas là ça à mon avis ça a marché
il donne des allumettes pourquoi ma
bougie va cet arbre bien sûr que nous on
n'a pas cette arme peut rallumer barèges
par lui mais des bruits au vite
non vous avez enfreint les règles
fallait pas rallumer la lumière vous ne
deviez pas allumer les lumières
j'en peux plus de ce jeu quand le minage
manoir près de nous il va et un la
bougie qu'on a 10 secondes pour rallumer
sinon père est le but du jeu c'est de
tenir jusqu à 3h33 du matin
le rituel commence sous leur coiffe et
sourcils dans cinq secondes
je veux que mes une allemagne trouve que
j'ai des beaux sourcils quand même la
moindre des choses hop on est bon c'est
là que non où sont les allumettes il
faut des allumettes mon gars il faut
absolument peut-être là entre eux ac
nous y [ __ ] j'ai pas vu des allumettes
là parfait on a des allumettes ça sent
le midnight man par ici un même toit
mais mal mais rallume toi mais la flamme
était sur la neige devrait faire un
chalumeau une éruption de fois quand je
ne sais pas oh non mais là c'est trop
court 1 je le dis haut et fort c'est le
dernier essai 1 g/t sur la berge avec
mon mac mais ma flamme j'ai vu la mèche
a fait un doigt d'honneur à la flamme
elle était comme ça non
donc je faisais le mafioso lemaitre je
fais le malin mais je n'ai pas de le
mettre en dehors n'a pas non plus de la
cuisine mais cette cuisine servira à
rien tout jamais j'ai deux allumettes
c'est simple l'agepar gardant cette
pièce au final non il ya que des balles
en mousse un peu partout n'a pas là
cachée d'air le fauteuil discrètement
non il n'ya pas d'allumettes mais non
mais c'est une blague là des allumettes
oui non ce n'est pas un savon c'était
une allumette mais ben hassine sud et en
direct ça suffit un en plus j'ai pas la
nausée donc alors si on voit ce soir
qu'est ce qu'on est au sous sol
mais là ya de la lumière annabaoui c'est
normal pour qu'on voie les marges quand
même à temps mais c'est pas un sous sol
c'est une grotte quoi de ce cas les 10
et 20 minutes il ya des bruits sympa
j'aime beaucoup ça me plait énormément
la allumettes allumettes
on est bien qu on est bien on a un stock
de 8 c'est tout mais [ __ ] mais c'est
des boîtes de radars et j'espère qu'il
fait pas 50 euros le mannequin il ya
deux allumettes de danse on y connait on
est à inventer et au moins tu encore au
montant encore non constructible orages
ok leurs passes [ __ ] mais il faut
tenir super longtemps ce n'est même pas
une heure encore qu'est ce qui se passe
monsieur midnight man
as tu penses vraiment que tu me fais
peur mon gars tu chies connu pire que
toi
à nous aussi s'envole par exemple aux
cages and to remake et je parle pas de
l'animal je parle de ce terrible objets
informatique diabolique au plus haut non
allez mais tout est dans le poignet on a
un bon moulinet pour pour les allumettes
là c'est pas mal vient pas des urnes est
là de l'autre côté sur cette table de
nuit dans ce tiroir
non là dedans pas des élus mettent là
dedans je suis sûr contre voilà entre
autres de livres on n'est pas mal
il est vrai hockey j'aime la vie il
était là vous l'avez y avait une tache
sombre dans le jeu passe comme ça pas
tentant papa comme ça comme ça même le
téléphone ne sonne et le piano s'active
une boîte d'allumettes souple et une
boîte d'allumettes et bas et ben ouais
enfin la boîte d'allumettes qui fait 200
ooo mais bon là on a quinze allumettes
mais on termine tranquillement
c'est génial comme principe quand même à
ya eu le bruit d'un projecteur oui
j'arrive c'est mon show au
je vais retourner dans le champ de ma
petite fille peut-être qu elle l est
sous cette pieuvre vent et à cordes
allumettes un de ces quatre on va
descendre
on a dû rater des élus mettent en bas un
jeu remonte finalement la doyenne boîte
d'allumettes j'en suis sûr bh je ne suis
pas moi et ben écoute c'est très bien
moi je suis moi mais je veux rester moi
n'est pas décédée d'accord alors tu te
cattin tenant à à une boîte d'allumettes
s'il vous plaît voire même un lance
flamme ou un chalumeau ou inachevé pour
le défoncer je possède une hache
attention à toi mon gars un coup de
hache c'est vite parti tu sais surtout
quand possède une maison de trois étages
ça aucun rapport mais bon hopu mais un
petit d'âge
allez si tu viens tu fais pas chier tu
prends des céréales moi c'est l'écrin
cote c dehors ça oui au revoir alors
monsieur midnight man on est à ma bouche
qu'est ce que c'est que ça nous on a vu
ses grands pieds quoi aller on a neuf
allumette pour une heure et demie c'est
un peu tendu
voilà coucou wet alaa non mais là c'est
la fin ni qu'elle sait faire mais il
faut qu'on trouve une clé
je suis sûr que assez une armurerie une
arme hull met même à 106 anything un vfi
king as hockey mes amis aujourd'hui est
un triste jour nous n'avons plus à lui m
nous avons un couteau on plante pétain
porte tant d'efforts pour rien et oui
j'ai un collier de chien
ok le midnight madden a eu donc on a
bien perdu devenir chiant bon et bien
voilà les gens c'est à dire fin de cette
vidéo j'espère que ça vous a plu ce cas
n'hésitez pas à aller bien comme
d'habitude ça fera vraiment plaisir
remettre votre casque en collier de
chien comme vous voulez aussi j'ai au
15e sur cette vidéo je serai pourquoi
sommes nous serons la team gascon
collier de chien tout cela doit cesser
ont surtout retrouvé dans une nouvelle
vidéo chat ou le monde pis
[Musique]